- I had to take out student loans
so that I could be able to go to college.
Thus far, that mission
has cost me $88,000.
I just think, gosh, couldn't
there have been a better way?
My name is Marvin Logan
and I have a mountain
of student loan debt.
I'm a first-generation college student.
I was an all-American track and
field athlete in high school
and due to those merits I was able to earn
a track and field scholarship
and then I got hurt and
that changed everything.
I had to take out student loans
to be able to compensate
for the athletic scholarship
that I had lost.
By the time that I
graduate with my masters
I'll be closer to $100,000 in debt.
I certainly think that it was worth it
but it was a high price to
pay to have a better life.
What is most important for me
is that I can take the
experiences that I've learned
and teach them to my students.
I work as a program assistant
for Usher's New Look
which is a non-profit organization
all about youth
development and leadership.
One of the things that I do in my work
is help students evaluate
and navigate student loans,
financial aid, figuring out
how to make the best choices
when going off to college
so they can continue
to develop as leaders.
Part of the reason that we've come
to the circumstances we have
in college affordability
is our lack of representation,
not just as young people,
but as people in general.
There are probably not too many things
that are more important in this world
than to stand up and be counted.
If you truly want to be stronger together,
if you truly want to
make America great again
you won't be able to do that
without a solid and sound
investment in education.
(lighthearted music)
(ding)